hello again this is part two of our
series about Sufism last time we spoke
about the early history and its basic
teachings and practices and today we're
gonna discuss its later developments
everything from medieval poetry to
modern times if anything Sufism has
become popular and known outside of
Islam through its different expressions
like poetry and literature and even
music and one of the most famous
ambassadors of Sufism in the West at
least is the persian poet Jalal add-in
Rumi he lived most of his life in Konya
turkey in the 13th century but is still
very popular today in fact recently he
was the best-selling poet in America
he's so famous that even Beyonce named
her daughter after him because he was
her favorite poet he's also the founder
of the novella via Order which features
our friends the whirling dervishes which
in itself has become one of the most
famous images of Sufism as well what
makes Rumi stand out is his incredibly
beautiful use of language to express the
intricate philosophies of Sufism often
through metaphors he much liker from the
Rabia from before puts a lot of emphasis
on love and intoxication in the divine
presence for example you'll find in his
poetry a lot of references to wine
drinking and drunkenness and people
falling hopelessly in love with
beautiful women and what these verses
are beautiful in themselves it should
also be remembered that when he talks
about intoxication and wine drinking
that is actually a metaphor for
intoxication in love for God and all of
roomies verses are really deeply rooted
in Sufism and Islam and here's an
example I am NOT of this world nor the
next nor of paradise nor of Hell I am
NOT of Adam nor of Eve nor of Eden and
there is one my place is the place less
my trace is the traceless it is neither
body nor soul for I belong to the soul
of the beloved I have put duality away I
have seen that two worlds are one one I
seek one I know one I see one I call I
am intoxicated with love's cup the two
worlds have passed out of my kin
I am so drunken in this world
that except of drunkenness and rivarly I
have no tale to tell
in this verse he expresses both
intoxication and love for God but also a
hint or indication of a unity and
connection between creator and created
in fact one can say semi problematically
that Sufism has tended to emphasize the
imminence of God in the world more than
other denominations this became perhaps
most prominently expressed by one of
Rumi's contemporaries Mohideen ibn
al-arabi and his followers in the school
that followed him in what became later
known as wada thelusian or the unity of
being empanada B presents a cosmology
were in terms of being or who should God
is actually everything that exists and
the world are his manifestations he
writes the following the world is
illusory it has no real existence you
have been made to imagine that the world
is something separate and independently
real outside of the absolute but in
reality this is not so now a banana B
should not be understood as a pantheist
or even panin theist as he very much
still maintains the transcendence and
incomparability of God to the world
while at the same time affirming his
eminence and sameness needless to say
this doctrine has been very
controversial and well it 'banahna be
himself maybe did not hear to the
philosophy of what outside were Jude as
it became known later many of his
followers did and it became a
significant part of later Sufi
philosophy discussions about what it
means and how it should be understood
has been a source of great debate
throughout history to his followers like
the famous Persian poet Jame he's known
as sheikh al akbar or the great master
the greatest master while for people
like eben tamiya which was his opponent
and the modern Wahhabi movements he is
often considered a heretic indeed since
medieval times and the influence of some
of the people I've talked about Sufism
eventually grew to become the form of
Islam practiced by the majority of the
world's Muslims right up until about the
middle or late 19th century and in some
parts of the world it still holds this
position for example in Senegal in which
92 percent of the population is Muslim
95% of those Muslims belonged to a Sufi
Brotherhood
order in other words Sufism is certainly
not a small sect of Islam as some people
tend to believe generally speaking there
are a lot of misunderstandings about
Sufism both in the non-muslim and Muslim
world as a result of some let's say
liberal translations of brumis work for
example many people have come to believe
that Sufism is something separated from
Islam and some form of general
spirituality but when we consider its
history we can clearly see that its
teachings are firmly rooted in Islam and
that the poetry of Rumi for example is
is often based on the Quran or the
hadith with that said within the limits
of Islam Sufism has devolved in many
different directions and taken on many
many forms throughout history it isn't
just a tradition consisting of ascetic
individuals living in poverty it's been
practiced by kings landowners military
personnel and people from all walks of
life any generalizations like this
including that Sufism is a peaceful
version of Islam should be viewed very
cautiously nonetheless Sufism is still
strong today and many of the old tariq
al Zour orders still have a large
following and some new ones have even
popped up from time to time like the
titania or the meridian in West Africa
Sufism is also often associated with
music today as many Sufi orders have
used music in their rituals for example
there is usand or from Senegal who
belonged to the Meridian and has had a
successful career in the West by among
other things working with people like
Peter Gabriel in his songs he often
sings about very important people from
West African Sufism like the Mara boots
or sheiks and also the prophets of Islam
he even has an album called Egypt that
is specifically written about Islam and
Sufism another good example is the
qawalli singer Nusrat Fateh Ali Khan
from the shish dia order he became
famous in the late 80s and 90s through
albums like most most there is more
interest in Sufism in the West generally
partly stemming from the popularity of
Rumi's poetry and also to some because a
new age interpretations of Sufism its
enormous diversity is really difficult
to grasp and a short video like this is
really insufficient to talk about it all
but with its increased presence in
Europe and North America
unfortunately also some news coverage
about violence committed against Sufis
like the mosque attack in Egypt back in
November
it seems relevant that we try to
understand its complex history and
different expressions after all things
are rarely very rarely as simple as we
like to believe I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]